vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir la tournée
africaine d'emmanuel macron se poursuit
après le cameroun le président français
au bénin outre la sécurité il a aussi
été question de coopération future
on vote pour les législatives au sénégal
ce dimanche la campagne bat son plein et
les candidats sillonnent le pays pour
convaincre les électeurs est pour
l'heure plutôt préoccupés par leur
quotidien entre les inondations et la
vie chère reportage à suivre
ce soir nous parlerons de finances avec
duplex kore gang il est camerounais
fondateur du délit une solution bancaire
digitales des 10 à 100 % aux étudiants à
mobilité internationale
après le cameroun le président français
est au bénin deuxième étape de sa
tournée africaine emmanuel macron s'est
entretenu avec son monologue 500
l'homologue béninois en plus des
demandes de matériel militaire il a
aussi été question de coopération
culturelle marque poupe
tout sourire emmanuel macron salue son
homologue béninois une visite de 24
heures au cours de laquelle les deux
chefs d'état se sont entretenus en tête
à tête au coeur de leurs discussions la
question sécuritaire dans une région où
les groupes terroristes se multiplient
on a besoin d'armements n'a besoin
d'équipements de matériels militaires et
en cela nous attendons un effort de
votre part nous avons les moyens
financiers
d'acquérir les équipements là nous
savons que vous avez les moyens de la
fournée des demandes entendue par les
autorités françaises qui émettent
toutefois quelques conditions président
m'a demandé des équipements plus
sophistiqués de drones de surveillance
et autres sur lesquels nous allons là
aussi dans les prochaines semaines avant
c'est pour répondre à la demande qui est
légitime mais nous ne faisons n'oubliant
jamais que la réponse sécuritaire doit
s'accompagner d'une réponse politique et
de développement c'est nous voulons
qu'elle soit pérenne autre sujet abordé
entre les deux hommes la coopération
culturelle emmanuel macron et patrice
talon ont visité l'exposition mettant à
l'honneur les 26 oeuvres restituer au
bénin par la france en novembre dernier
un partenariat qui devrait se poursuivre
dans les prochains mois s'agissant des
nouveaux axes de restitution comme je
m'y étais engagé à l'occasion de votre
visite à paris le 9 novembre dernier je
souhaite que nous puissions poursuivre
le travail aller au bout et porter cette
loi cadre qui sera présenté dans les
meilleurs délais pour sa première visite
sur le continent africain depuis sa
réélection emmanuel macron cherche donc
à renforcer ses alliances après le
cameroun et le bénin le chef de l'état
se rend ce jeudi en guinée-bissau
et ça c'est partie des thèmes de cette
visite on a appris d'une source
judiciaire que 30 opposants arrêtés
durant la présidentielle en avril 2021
au bénin avait été remis en liberté
au lendemain du débat télévisé qui
devait rassembler les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle kenyane la
campagne a repris comme si de rien
n'était pourtant ce débat n'a pas tenu
ses promesses seuls deux des quatre
prétendants s'y sont rendus raïla odinga
et william ruto les deux favoris était
ce mercredi dans la région dumont
clignant kenya où étaient nos
correspondants bastien renouil et
vivienne bandeira
do très nombreux téléspectateurs ont eu
l'impression d'assister à une mascarade
plus qu'à un débat puisque seuls deux
des quatre candidats ont fait le
déplacement et parmi les deux candidats
qui ont des chances d'être élu seul
l'actuel vice président du kenya wheeler
à moto a effectué le déplacement raila
odinga avait annoncé quelques jours
auparavant qu'il ne se déplacerait pas
afin de ne pas donner de tribune à
l'actuel vice-président qui a pu
dérouler son programme durant une heure
et demie devant deux journalistes qu'ils
n'ont pas réellement contredit alors ici
ce meeting de williams au taux auquel je
me trouvais bien de nombreuses personnes
étaient extrêmement contente de
l'intervention du vice président
d'autres ne comprennent pas pourquoi
raila odinga ne s'est pas déplacé et
d'autre soutenez ce choix je vous
propose de les écouter
c'était un bon débat rousseau a bien
répondu aux questions j'ai beaucoup aimé
sa façon de parler avec courage
les coquets raïla odinga a vexé de
nombreux kényans mais c'était son droit
de participer ou de ne pas le faire
déjà des beckham en quoi ça nous les
partisans d'odinga nous sommes contents
car nous nous attendions un très mauvais
comportement de william ruto il parle
mal aux gens ils déforment leurs propos
nous ne voulions pas coding à soit
confronté à la propagande de routot
alors si la bataille télévisuelle n'a
pas eu lieu elle a lieu réellement sur
le terrain me trouve aujourd'hui sur les
pentes du mont kenya où a lieu en
meeting de chacun des deux principaux
candidats à cette élection ici ce sont
des soutiens de william ruto et je peux
vous dire que les deux candidats tente
d'obtenir à les votes des derniers
kikuyu indécis les kikuyus et l ethnie
la plus importante du pays qui n'a pas
de candidat désigné une bataille a en
parallèle qui aura lieu jusqu'à la fin
de la campagne électorale le 6 août
prochain les deux hommes ont d'ailleurs
réservé le même stade pour leur dernier
meeting pour l'instant la justice n'a
pas tranché on sait pas lequel des deux
candidats aura accès à ce stade ce
dernier grand meeting électoral dit
où passe au sénégal où les électeurs
sont aussi appelés au vote ce dimanche
il faut renouveler l'assemblée nationale
165 députés hui lice dont la coalition
présidentielle gbagbo qui a caressé de
l'opposition et oui askan wi
les candidats sillonnent le pays pour
convaincre les électeurs mais ils
semblent plus préoccupés par leur
quotidien
entre les inondations les examens de fin
d'année et surtout la vie chère à dakar
le reportage de nos correspondants et
les mengao sam brad pitt et sarah sa
coupe
longue or un quartier populaire de la
capitale sénégalaise l'heure est aux
petits déjeuners dans la buvette de
maddie guen
cette mère de famille est bien connu
dans son quartier pour ses sandwichs
ces derniers temps son commerce tourne
au ralenti les clients se font rares et
les produits sont plus chers
la vie est dure je m'en sors à peine
avec ce petit commerce parce que tout
est devenu très cher au marché je
travaille pour presque aucun bénéfice
comme mehdi guen de nombreux sénégalais
subissent l'inflation la guerre en
ukraine et la hausse du prix de
l'énergie ont perturbé la reprise post
co vide malgré les mesures adoptées par
le gouvernement les prix explosent
ousmane est employée dans un restaurant
pour joindre les deux bouts ils vont des
poulets qui l'élève sur son toit
la nourriture pour volaille est devenu
très très cher le prix du sac de graines
ne coûte presque 40% plus cher que
l'année dernière
minute pour moi il y à vraiment urgence
à ce que les prix baissent
l'inflation et subit encore plus
durement par ceux qui ne travaillent pas
gibril et retraités ils touchent moins
de 150 euros de pension perçue elle sait
survie dépend aujourd'hui de la
solidarité de sa communauté
une grande famille
[Musique]
c'est dans ce contexte économique
difficile que près de 7 millions de
sénégalaises se rendront aux urnes ce
dimanche la cherté de la vie est l'un
des thèmes de cette campagne électorale
est sans aucun doute un dossier que
devront traiter les futurs députés
quatre personnes sont mortes
électrocutées lors d'une manifestation
contre les casques bleus à ouvrira dans
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo dans la matinée un groupe de
jeunes avait tenté d'associer j'ai le
quartier général de la mission de l'onu
en rdc de la ville la police alors usé
des tirs de sommation pour les disperser
ce qui a fait tomber des lignes à haute
tension qui est tombée sur les
manifestants et qui serait mort
électrocuté
une triste nouvelle pour la presse
africaine et algérienne en particulier
le grand quotidien francophone el watan
est menacé de disparition après 31 ans
d'existence une fermeture qui s'impose
car aucun plan de règlement de la crise
n'a été soumis aux partenaires social
pour rappel les 150 salles employés sont
sans salaire depuis cinq mois et ont
entamé une grève de deux à trois jours
chaque semaine depuis le 12 juillet
notre invité du journal ce soir est un
entrepreneur et un investisseur né dans
une famille modeste à douala au parcours
brillant qui a travaillé en allemagne et
en france avant de se lancer tout seul à
37 ans il lance une plateforme digitale
de fintec il y a cinq ans tu délit il
start up qui accompagne les étudiants
africains dans leur installation en
europe ça c'était le point de départ un
projet déjà plusieurs fois primé qui
s'est étendue duplex comme dame merci
d'être notre invité son le journal de
l'afrique france 24 merci flotte matin
merci pour l'invitation alors tu délit
dit nous déjà comment est né ce projet
je sais que c'est parti de votre propre
expérience union oui c'est parti de ma
propre expérience d'étudiant et c'est
aussi partie de celles de mes co
fondateur que je salue d'ailleurs et que
nous avions vécu cela il ya plus de
douze ans pour moi en tout cas et pour
d'autres beaucoup plus longtemps on
s'est dit plus jamais ça on ne
souhaitait plus que les étudiants
puissent vivre cette galère là en gros
poutous simplement pour qu'un étudiant
puces à l'étudiant à l'étranger
notamment en france il doit justifier
auprès du consul 1,2 des ressources
financières pour pouvoir obtenir en
visant ils doivent aussi justifier le
fait d'avoir un logement quand on sait
que c'est très très compliqué lorsqu'on
ne vit pas par exemple en france pour
trouver un logement et aussi pour
justement ce jusqu'à types de ressources
soient en fait c'est une attestation
qu'il peut prendre au niveau d'une
banque en déposant les fonds ont
préalablement et cette banque l'uml
attestation pour prouver aux consulats
que chaque mois il aura le un douzième
de la somme déposée pendant 12 mois au
niveau de la france et le consulat fort
de ce document peut délivrer justement
le viseur d'accord donc vous vous les
accompagnez alors dites nous comment ça
se passe concrètement aux étudiants et
aux parents d'étudiants qui nous
écoutent en ce moment partout sur le
continent et ailleurs parce que je sais
que ça c'est ouvert comment fonctionne
la plateforme studélites concrètement la
plateforme se délite complètement
fonctionne tout simplement en ligne ce
studélites points comme les étudiants
peuvent créer encore et pour créer ce
compte ils ont juste besoin de digérer
les maîtres leur passeport et la lettre
d'admission parce qu'il faut être admis
justement pour obtenir l'attestation et
ensuite ils doivent choisir le lieu où
ils souhaitent payer parce qu'en afrique
dans certains pays on propose des
étudiants de déposer les fonds en local
ou bien de déposer systématiquement en
france et une fois que ils ont signé le
contrat bien évidemment qui en ligne et
ensuite ils ont un rib ils doivent
déposer les formes et une fois qu'ils
ont déposé les fonds nous ont fait les
validations et ils obtiennent leur
attestation nous on les accompagne au
delà de ce document là aussi dans le
cadre de leur recherche d'autres
documents comme le logement est aussi
des conseils précieux pour leur
préparation avant d'arriver en france
oui évidemment il ya cette préparation
donc cette partie administrative et la
partie bancaire aussi parce que c'est
une fine taquet une solution
bancaire digital aussi effectivement et
ça j'en remercie d'ailleurs de
l'introduire en fait justement je suis
aussi là pour ça parce que on s'est posé
la question avec mémé cofondateur de on
a résolu en quatre ans la problématique
de justifier les ressources auprès du
consulat de trouver un logement mais on
s'est rendu compte qu'il est on est
resté sur notre faim en à savoir
lorsqu'on étudiants arrivent en france
qu'il n'a pas le logement s'il veut
aller trouver un logement le bailleur
lui demande un compte bancaire s'il va
aller ouvrir un compte bancaire à la
banque que les règlements logement adam
c'est un peu le chat qui se mord des
lacs on s'est dit il faut plus jamais ça
depuis il depuis ses débuts de cette
année tu délires mis en place une
solution de comptes de paiement qui se
déroule sur deux faces est très
important ce que je vais dire la
première phase en fait l'étudiant peut
depuis son pays depuis dakar depuis
yaoundé où et depuis d'autres pays comme
cotonou pour ouvrir ce compte avec 4
avec une application mobile ouvrez un
compte de paiement avec un dribble
française et pouvoir payer ses frais de
scolarité par exemple payer son logement
et sur la deuxième phase qui arrive
d'ici à partir du 1er septembre
l'étudiant pourra effectuer tous ces
opérations financières notamment faire
des virements et autres après les cartes
bancaires et pour aller commander à son
arrivée après les dates comme le 30
novembre un accord est alors justement
pour ça il faut de l'argent est ce qu'il
ya une prochaine levée de fonds pour ce
délit ah oui déjà là dans vient
d'accueillir un investisseur assez
important pour nous c'est un partenaire
qui s'appelle smera et qui justement
investi dans notre société qui est
partenaire avec nous depuis longtemps et
qui est le premier le premier groupe
mutuelle étudiante de france et avec qui
nous ont porté des très fortes ambitions
donc il vient d'investir une somme assez
importante que je ne dirais pas ici
oui et nous on est en train de
travailler en ce moment pour pouvoir
accueillir d'autres investisseurs
d'ailleurs je lance un appel aux
investisseurs qui souhaitent justement
accompagné des sociétés comme stu délit
nous on a lancé une opération de levée
de fonds qui va commencer d'ici
septembre et vous étendre d'ici fin
d'année merci bravo bravo duplex quand
bon vous souhaite tout le meilleur pour
ce délit et bien d'autres choses
évidemment tous vos projets
d'investissement c'est ainsi que nous
refermons ce journal de l'afrique merci
à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis le
maintien de douala à yaoundé en passant
par gare ou à rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]